you can let him win some games not to
make him sad yeah I just have to make
sure not to let him win all the games I
think that's a goal like just get at
least one draw or one win I'll be
satisfied but no really that the goal is
just to play like good chess to try and
have interesting games I'm very grateful
to like be here like just having a match
against world number 13 I think
shout-out to the YouTube people watching
in the future also shout-out to chess
weeb welcome back let's go
so the challenge has been sent okay
goodbye checks okay
London time g5 what is g5 some weird
prep might see three I guess oh he meant
to play g6 but he mouse slipped
I thought he had speared prep that's so
funny he meant to play g6 I thought this
was something like secret preparation
okay I have to stay calm I mean normally
idea is h4 h5 and there's no more pawn
in g6
open ah Danny five play III
in Bishop d3h for typical ideas and
here's H 5 H 5 H 6 ideas some have four
ideas to that for mine Bishop gets
trapped
I play e6 perhaps u6 takes I could take
on g6 - mm-hmm it's tricky takes takes
six ticks mean this looks Pleasant I'm
like h5 in the end I know any Queen d3
you have seven expect over 95 ah I gave
back the pawn but the position should
still be pleasant you some at for ideas
later a rookie one is risky and
queenside castling even more risky could
be one night see 491 I'll go for this
I'll play a lot faster castling
oh no he's running digit xe3 oh my gosh
like a castle castling defends most
things in Queen g-41 during the night to
g3 and just be safe I just not a 4 to 92
94 FF 4 as well a playoff for
some rock f3 just trying to be safe
catch up on time
take stakes on positions objectively not
good for me maybe King H - no time not
good either
some b3 ideas rooks tied down on b1
I want to take on e5 and play 94
actually and g4 could be very nice
square is preventing that of course to
move the King thing off the diagonal
takes takes e5 is gonna come but okay d5
is hanging
let's tackle the d5 pawn can take Ono to
b3 I guess don't know why flight 93 it's
gonna be a time scramble
brookey two ideas
No ah now slip okay I was unfortunate
the holiday slip rematch I mean my
position wasn't great but in the time
situation some nerves okay I forgot to
update the score all up to you that
after the scheme d3 okay he's gonna play
King's India yeah but new for the
Knights
like I'll play Bishop a7 maneuvering
that Knight to g6 just have to be solid
I roped Yates might have four ideas too
while c5 can I take that
mmm I can also take on d4
yeah next c4 okay the t3 doesn't work
let's play Queen c7 Bishop takes d4
we'll trade some nine each five nine if
for ideas I get the chance I want to
play c5 it okay II five wow so 95 most
natural Contrave I'm gonna have b5 and
end mmm okay let's trade once you mean
like before before visit you six it's
gonna put the nine on d6
96 workout fades just try and hold my
own I have the d5 square which is nice
I also have a 95 and then I take c5
ideas I think III just helped me so I
think I am threatening to take on e5
those now this Knights kind of stranded
I take b7 i take with check let's take
here 85 some you lost
each 4 is kind of being attacked III
expected oh no I can't take they're
almost boat s gander did like Queen f6
nice time advantage
oh wait free ruck what free Brooke right
no sneaky traps I like free drugs okay
one one not bad score 1-1 okay
it's very generous I clicked rematch
there we go okay let's try and settle
down he's gonna play g6 this time or
that okay play the slang
se5 expected okay we're going into this
stuff we have appearance I was watching
his banter blitz he's usually like he
was also fond of playing this as black
and c5 me becoming trying to remember
craftman you c5 I think I can either
take her I play d5 trying to remember
I'm Bishop h6 ideas
there there be five takes takes takes
takes now I'll some retaking first and
then II five next because the Knights
attacked and okay the D pawn is pinned
if there's 94-94 trying to remember prep
it's been a while I think I can take
take windey 497 I can take on d6
actually yeah this is essentially a four
because I'm I have four attackers on d6
and the depands pinned
I have a huge time advantage to my H
five should have expected that
I'm Bishop h6 perhaps it's typical move
I can't take on e5 yet
that's very nice having time advantage
it takes takes each three move I'm
taking Queen d4 maybe I'll but he's
gonna take with Knights and can I just
simplify everything just take on g6 when
upon
okay so I'm up a pawn and structures not
so great to take and play this rookie
one that's a move Bishop d5 and rookie
one coming sneaky move might be five
ideas like to get in before I could
passively defend not so desirable but
I'll do it
what to do here a 3 B 4 wants to play 94
mm maybe this move
just try and trade I wanna get in C 3
and bring my king to the the King side
I'll take
okay it's gonna be a time scramble game
again bring the King to g2 it's just an
equal pretending just have to play
quicker
a five work H 5 H 5 work g 6 I'm gonna
king around blocks King a little bit
more active black also down in time
dropped upon and this should be easy
flag free pong sorry Peter just have to
play quicker okay to won the first game
is slightly haunting me but happens how
do i rematch something weird happened
here
I guess all rescind or way challenges
weights I'll accept okay there we go how
I accept
when I'm black again
okay I've published one of my goals c4 I
didn't prepare for c4 l86 yeah I'll just
play this line this is line I've been
playing for many years he's gonna try
and punish me a quick fashion rook a six
maybe I want to play c5 quickly I think
sooner rather than later Queen b6 can
usually be thrown in
I do own a castle as well yeah c5 is
usually the main approach you wants to
play e4 I don't castle first before I'm
wondering if before can work let's start
with this move looks solid
I mean I'm under a little bit of
pressure but I don't think it's so bad
rook f2 you coming and then eventually
see 595 I think is safe oh no 95 just
blenders everything no good to do bad
still some nerves what to do how much am
i down I'm down a rook I mean I could
resign
yeah I don't want to play this how I
resign resign okay
how's bad where's a rematch button oh
very this okay sad game to to okay
d4 repeat the opening I'm expecting I'll
play something different at 5:00 I'll
play I'll still play a London cell up
now he played this and the Grand Prix
recently I should have prepared this I
didn't look at this so closely but I do
have a line against this place e5 c6 so
soon you see five still should be okay
sirs take some Queen e5
and quindi for maybe 24 ideals of before
marriage five quincy for
looks interesting it's hard to calculate
Oh a 90 h5f Bishop e5 well this actually
looks quite nice if I get before and
then most problems are solved
and like the light squares are a bit
weak for black like Bishop c4 ideas and
that a six very playable good castle
could take the thing
so if I take
hmm
that's hard to Castle I should probably
take though
miles to do his work - you are queenside
castling I was like it kind of almost
works rook do you want similar idea
promised Bishop e6
well maybe a three let's play a three
I'm calculating a queen takes e5 bishop
takes a 6-point a c4 Knight a c4 b takes
a six and then Knight takes c6 C as
Bishop e7 and end um maybe I don't want
to take moving too slowly though let's
go for this giving away the pawn I play
much much quicker each for Slovak has
two bishops I'm down a pawn but it
doesn't feel so bad it's time as the
biggest culprits not sure if trading
rooks is great or not I'll bring a
knight to c5
in pong before at some point and then 93
to c5
what's kind of annoying it's my plan
Bishop here maybe try and win a pawn and
Bishop goes back to be eights so you
gonna play off for before I have time to
take it I Bishop h2
hmm take 6 takes a 4 in the end have to
go for this by breaking through I don't
think so
this might be a draw actually I don't
flag
Wow
now I'll practice my pre moving
Peter can practices meeting with king
and queen that's so close to drawing
okay he's ahead two three not the end of
the world
rematch he's enjoying playing like a lot
of different things this unprepared for
now this is a slight side variation I'll
include knight c6 rather than poncey 596
that time very important in beginning
here not to waste much much precious
seconds interesting move let's include
Brooke t8 I'm not going to hang you
sodden again this game by a five
okay usually ideas night c59 is a little
bit weird on b3 restricted by my pawns
I could play a four okay five ideas it's
interesting trade on d4 expecting 94
for Dungey to Queen be saddened and then
Knight c5 c6 is a bit weak takes takes
hmm I have to put the rook back on
Yeates it's not so pleasant but I'll
survive least I'm restricting Queen side
play also take on c5 hmm b5 doesn't work
what to play maybe at six I mean maybe
rook c8 first getting outplayed though
just have to make it a long game
I'll take with Bishop and the night is
very annoying it would be five here
eventually King f8 it should be six and
then just wait I guess I also have f6 oh
well before so I have to take play
Bishop f8 so passive though maybe a rook
f8 no know what to do
could cry it's leaking
yeah King f8 I have to watch out for an
87 check and then takes
ah takes takes a loosey seven
but the work on a six some activity
look here
oh dear this is not good or my tricks
it's really not good
I just have to like curl up in a ball
and slowly die maybe flag g5 okay I got
g5 in I want to play King some King
activity someday h5 may be played Bishop
g1 hopefully who plays rook a7 and guess
about my bishop
now this is just so grotesque um you
rook have six know I could sack that
would actually be nice
I'll sack
hello I'm getting forts no stalemate
tricks
oh that's a checkmate oh so sad well
update the schoo he didn't check me me
I'd made him one
okay I'm gonna resign I'll update the
score okay I was still a fight just got
outplayed and uh some somewhere in the
middle game once and I got to see six
but I mean I was still like happy about
the opening okay
mainline London let's go should have
fired
so I file so soon affinity to
and this looks interesting 94 ideas I
think a three is a typical approach oh
I'm hanging upon and see to what I see
two is falling but Bishop e5 there's
some counter play he doesn't take just
be safe well played before
Queen Queen c2 defends everything works
e8 I won't have a threat its castle
I'm entirely sure what to do just have
to try and hold my ground every night g3
ideas to play quickly Queenie to ideas
he hasn't like c4 ideas let's play b3
all the Knights rooks defended now let's
play Queen d2 Queenie to trade and then
eventually b3 or we'll just trade off
everything this is what I need just in
quiet position I'll bring the knight to
d3 very soon some Bishop c7 ideas too
yeah idea is just bring the King to see
- I know Peter doesn't like these types
of like dry symmetrical positions would
be three work I also play Knight B -
he's making things interesting doesn't
it be - I'm 91 I'll be 83 is a week but
ok like Knights yeah this should be fine
are you gonna have Knight c3 Knight c3
bishop be a perhaps just safeguarding
against 92 takes a 3 I take a 7 it's a
fair trade to keep the time advantage
okay for once play 92 now well that's
actually kind of annoying so play at 392
b5
or before b5 I have ideas of bringing
the Bishop to c5 hmm play this move
oh no I'm pawns hanging to play this
move
Bishop c5 ideas Bishop you want ideas
now I should not put plans on dark space
yeah I'll accept the draw right don't
break through okay score 0.55 okay
I have to play to drag these games on
longer for a win I want a chance
Bishop c4 okay so he's evading or
avoiding me mines
oh he tricked me into Italian I have to
play this someone opening I didn't want
to play
I'd do this idea I can do this idea this
was a one idea I know in Italian to play
eventually age 396 and then eventually
f5 I take take and take on each three
oh there's rook takes you four but then
d5 I don't see what he's doing here it's
tactics
I'd use Bishop g4 next pieces are
aligned then the Nilan f3 is not having
sufficient defenders
yeah okay so I have the pin Queen have
six ideas might you 7 2 G 6 5 4 ideas
it's a very arrow worthy position maybe
seven or maybe Queen f6 first we have
six first defending h6 and then 97 if
take c7 I can take h4 meanwhile I just
want to win upon
my position looks very good just have to
stay calm let's take with the night
first lots of color Bishop's yeah bring
the King to g7 you see 65 any pawns on
my up I'm up two pawns it's a lot of
pawns he's doing weird stuff and take
I'm taking play a five and they should
be six hey Ricky seven first in Bishop
c5 coming for k1 Bishop b6 c3 is a bit
tender let's bring this rook he's doing
annoying things let's defend like this
man Bishop T for ideas I've had I have a
passed pawn um let's play for this move
even double up behind the a pawn
ambition T for ideas
hmm to see three to be four oh my gosh
are you serious oh that's so bad take
six
oh it's so so bad
still get away with this
to move a lot quicker
Bishop on c5
No aah
such a good game too so sad what to do a
lot b6
okay just stay calm stay focused should
give me confidence so get some more
juice after this game I'm gonna pour
some more juice a London opening again
okay he's now he's playing his main line
it's play play dice move 96 ideas no he
fell for this like a similar trap in a
previous pantalets but he's not gonna
fall very here so the bishop was still
in my fate I have a knight g5 this is
still looking Pleasant though he's in
playoff six probably I have ideas of
taking an e4
okay another huge time advantage just
have to start converting these games
I'm taking castle
this looks reasonable he takes I take
with night I'm probably not gonna take
this pawn the Queen to is some simple
safe moose mp3 work t1 Bishop e1
eventually okay he can't win the pawn
immediately goes the rook falls in the
end oh can you win a - I'd be a greedy
move okay I'm solid you six is weak d4
kind of weak a relatively balanced
position if I take also play Bishop
efore there could be a lot of trade soon
it's tense threatening to take in Queen
e6 perhaps Bishop before so can I take
immediately I can and if Queen takes I
take on e6 of pawn takes when you six
King h8 rookie - what free pawn also the
rook is hanging on c7 but free pawn
where's Roxy one well there's some
compensation I have to play rook f1 I
guess I've rook e8 - a rookie a king f7
doesn't quite work work off one takes
takes 91 it's over this
another good position time advantage
play rookie to take stakes is a four I
have to get back the pond go for each
four and then takes work see one what to
do here
you look d1 and like d5 d6 it stops me
but okay now I can defend
I'll see plays rook c3 but then rupee
one rupee - I've rook to e3
I made a loo for my king of c3 Wow
tickle the pawn just stuck like each 5
nights for oh my gosh he's breaking
thrive - sack can't even sack takes
takes takes takes you mean maybe this
line isn't so bad oh no it's so bad
or is it allowing him to Queen
it's not fortunates ruff another good
position yeah y'all played me six and a
half okay let me try I'm trying to fight
I'm trying to fight rematch I got my
mighty I got my own I'd blueberry juice
okay another one of these but I like the
opening last time it was nice
I'll try another Italian Bishop a seven
yeah h3 have expected I'll go for this
plan will be similar to my first black
game c6 may be Bishop e6 may be Queen c7
Bishop e6 d4 rook e8 looks natural I'm
just trying to hold my own
I mean each six is a move to do t5d five
take sticks I think it's okay
oh maybe a plunders and do you find my
plunger played Bishop b8 weird move but
I want to play d5 I'm target the Queen
on the D file hmm that's slightly
annoying take stakes
okay things are getting really messy
now h5 Queenie southern I'm just about
to get smashed it might be about to have
triple pawns actually at least Mike
Bishop serves a purpose on B aids triple
pawns three times was good if tanks I
okay not happening I could take here but
F for undefended now takes have to play
off six so ugly
maybe rook
how bad is this I lost a pawn but I have
two bishops and I have more open files
rook f6 perhaps everything defended whoa
what does this move should g6 my dad oh
my gosh I'm about to be dead I'm down
the exchange I have two bishops not for
long
oh oh this is rough this is really rough
to play this no I can't even defend Oh
what to do
now I resign
I was really rough okay oh man seven and
a half this could be the last game let's
not let's try and get at least one more
some kind of points just build some
juice okay spilling juice is some sign
of good luck in some culture right okay
um comeback time two and a half seven
and a half
let's go no mercy a Dutch again I'll
play the same line as earlier I like the
position I might play it slightly
differently but it was interesting last
time he's playing it slightly
differently c6o maybe 83 console a 94 94
bucks he won Wow I can play b4 you just
plunder
oh it's Queen c7 but okay before Queen
c7 Bishop g3 still ideas a c5
I do not want this to be the last game I
don't want the next like four or five
means to be the next game or though the
last game I like the position again see
five ideas take stakes and c5 is very
nice idea
the Queen's tied down to the fending e5
if if efore which maybe is most expected
I can play 92 it's a reasonable move can
I take take six takes probably not c5 is
questionable
Bishop h4
just preserving the bishop threatening
Knight takes d5
let's don't want to play c5 I think it's
a reasonable move actually many pieces
are better so the center opening up
should favor me play this move say the
center is closing down oh man
Bishop g3 or takes first
take stakes let's do this because
Knights will be better than bishops in
this position
this Bishop's quite happy outside the
pawn chain if takes takes my rook will
be happy F for a while before I could
take taking them put Knights on e 2 and
E 3
okay I'm Queen b3 ideas we'll have to
watch out
I mean b3 sakip on
clear up team one
not so comfortable
play rock to you one
click wing me 323 ideas
so queen of five we have six
to bring the Knights this is not looking
good
might be three
you reckon yeah the rook belongs on our
phone we need some ability
if III f4
and then there's Queen h4 have to live
with it King bee one hmm I take I can
play this move to play rook g1 though
everything's falling apart
I'm just on a time scramble okay too
oh dear
please just hang your queen hanger
a'queen don't see my rook
that's gonna need it I got needed uh
good match good match
he played well he's good at chess ah
feel like I started off decently I just
had some unreasonable blunders lose some
good positions and there was some
psychological setbacks I'm happy to at
least have the opportunity also happy
not to like lose all the games auntie
was thanks for the bits yeah okay
hopefully a good learning experience off
to go through some of those games that
could have been by there could've been
worse
congratulations sis fiddler I mean so
the bracket also let me open up the
chats wow thank you so many people for
for being here sticking around I wish I
could have put up more of a fight
I'm Alice fiddler in a few days I think
he's doing commentary in st. Louis for
the the Grantchester event I'm curious
how much like he prepared for me if he
prepared at all okay I prepared a lot of
openings for him I was not expecting him
to trick me into Italian some of all the
things I did expect from him that first
game my first game is gonna haunt me see
mouse slept on move to with g5 that was
a free pawn I just it's a bit nervous
hammer in the chat shout out to you and
Ludwig hammer tried to pronounce that
correctly chess we've thanks for
sticking around Peter said he hopes to
see me and st. Louis so he can buy me a
beer that'll be a nice nice gift yeah
I'm I'm gonna probably see him a decent
amount or we're both doing work for the
Grand chefs to her event coming up so
sadly I'm knocked out of the 2019 banter
glitz Cup but I had some moments had a
good first match had some interesting
games in this match I feel like openings
were decent it was just like once the
middle game came I was getting out
playing I even got I'll play like in
that position of two pawns what to do
yeah beer beer does cloud mind and
judgment which is why I've been my my
drinks of choice lately have been
smoothies and tea I took some limes mean
this morning supposed to improve focus
and memory
but yeah thank you everyone
ice ice if you just joined you're here
coming at the very end but this this was
like this was a new experience for me
like having a multiple game match again
it's like a top 30 player in the world I
mean just doesn't happen every day or
every like decade it's probably the
first time I've had like a multi game
match or at least the second time like
maybe the first time was the more Oreo
match was I saying
you should try coffee + lion's mane I've
never heard of tea on Qi I'll look into
that
yeah I don't have any shame I'm slightly
disappointed and like in some positions
I couldn't converts I'm not used to
having like crushing positions and it's
like super GM's so it's one of these
psychological things like just it's
matter of getting more experience I'm
hoping they have this this tournament
next year I would love to to do this
again thank you so much just twenty four
I think the main person behind this is
David Martinez it's been very responsive
and helping get everything set up and
there's gonna be a lot of exciting
matches I'm hoping actually that let me
bring up the bat and the bracket first
here it is okay so here are the matches
like this giant brackets Carlson is
going to play Cuenca
oh let me see if I can remove this
there you know yeah oh wait I got rid of
myself where did I go here I am
and yeah okay
so this will be like I think this is one
of the most anticipated matches Carlson
against quaint go as cuenca has like
incredible Spanish commentary and if we
see my bracket oh so that I didn't even
know this but though the winner of our
match which is Peter moves on to play
goes Olli I'm hoping to see a US fiddler
Robson match in the third round that
should be interesting
breathe and just joining I lost a lot of
games I drew a game I won two games the
final score was eight and a half to two
and a half but I I butchered a lot of
like good or winning positions I think I
only had one Mouse it just still too
much but at least it wasn't more yeah so
if you're joining right now which maybe
a lot of people are I'll be posting this
to YouTube tomorrow the full match I
think Peters commentary should already
be on YouTube as it was streamed on
Twitch YouTube Facebook etc